divide and turn out that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
all right here's what we know tonight
about the state of America
mortgage demand plummets as rates are
going higher workers have essentially
had 24 months now of pay cuts
public pessimism about the economy hit
an all-time high under Biden oh boy
layoffs they're coming today maida
announced it's cutting 4 000 more
technical employees
and as DeSantis slugging it out with
Disney Disney is reportedly cutting 7
000 jobs including 15 percent of its
entire entertainment division ESPN
they're getting hit and hit hard more
layoffs there
and of course Biden's war against cars
continues gas prices have reached a
five-month high
now as all of this is Weighing on us
there's no end in sight as well for the
war in Ukraine the Biden Harris
Administration will announce a new
security assistant package for Ukraine
the announcement will be the 36th use of
presidential drawdown authorities to
support Ukraine
200 plus million dollars more and some
of the biggest economies in the world
countries we all thought were our allies
are now aligning with China first macron
in France he went to Beijing and Lula in
Brazil followed
while in Beijing Lula met with his
Chinese counterpart Xi Jinping and vowed
to strengthen ties and as stephanopus
reports Brazil's leader also took a few
swipes at the dominance of the U.S
dollar
shocking not all right I'm not going to
belabor the obvious about the Border
it's an open sewer of fentanyl cartels
and human trafficking all due to Biden's
policies in the ending of title 42.
there isn't even anything to debate here
anymore Biden is a complete and utter
disaster on all fronts he's an
embarrassment on the world stage
all the business enterprises they look
at me like hey guys don't jump okay I've
been in and out of Iraq and Iran Iraq
and Iran but Iraq not Iran on fires as a
consequence of the long uh the the
the utility poles you put up and all the
rest oh the utility pole problem yeah
is a complete incompetent and no one
believes he's calling any of the shots
no one is better off than they were
pre-pandemic when Trump was President so
given all of that which everyone if
you're really being honest
everyone agrees with what on Earth
should we expect from Biden if he does
run and from the Democrats in general
going into 2024.
I'll tell you what to expect divide and
demonize that's all they have forget
hope and optimism remember Obama's hope
and change that's out the window expect
only old school machine style Petty
politics
if he wants to get elected with this
nightmarish record of his Biden has to
divide the country into villains and
victims
and whoever they deem as worthy victims
will be elevated to hero status and
they're going to get rewarded and
whoever they paint is evil will be
punished and severely
so in every speech on every trip he'll
try to shift attention away from his and
his party's abject failures to the bad
people out there on the other side
he can't win without dividing us the
stories they choose to inject themselves
into will only be ones that Advance
their political narrative this is why
they'll give a hero's welcome to the
Tennessee three but not to the families
of the Nashville Christian shooting
one day you're going to have three of
the lawmakers who protested
peacefully protested who peacefully
protested after the Nashville Covenant
School shooting have any of the victims
or the victims families been invited to
the White House I don't have anything to
to read out to you about any invite why
I just don't have anything at this time
to read out to you at any invite what I
can say to you right now is that the
president is focused on getting things
done he's focused on making sure that we
are protecting our communities
protecting our communities well why
doesn't Biden spend any time then
talking about the violent crimes being
perpetrated by roving kids in places
like Chicago and Compton
well don't expect Democrats to spend a
lot of time on those stories because
they do not Advance The Narrative that
America's racist
same with the horrible sweet 16 shooting
in Alabama
these are not the accused they're not of
a white officer involved shooting or a
white on black killing so they don't get
the play
of course the Liberals have lots of
proxies though in the media in Hollywood
Corporate America they're all helping
them out and of course we can't forget
the activist crowd
people who cash in on the LIE that our
country is systemically racist
well there's no money in suing gang
bangers in Chicago who leave behind a
trail of death there's no Fame in
pursuing the scourge of black on black
violence that rips apart entire
communities
instead they wait they wait for the
perfect fact pattern like an 84 year old
white guy who shoots a black teen who
mistakenly walked onto his doorstep it
was a white man who shot their 16 year
old son it is
inescapable
not to
observe the racial Dynamics here but if
the roles were reversed and you had a
black man shoot a 16 year old white
child for simply ringing his doorbell
and the police took him in for
questioning and let him come home and
sleep in his bed at night how much
outrage would there be in America
victims are victims skin color should
not matter
but he obvious it obviously does to
Democrats in the media exploiting their
suffering only to feed their sick lie
that America is racist and yeah Trump
voters they are too
now Biden's inviting Rafael ralphiara
the black teen to the White House
but no invite for the family of Kalyn
Gillis who was shot when she went up the
wrong driveway in Upstate New York last
week that girl died but she was white so
her death didn't help Biden
Now understand what the Democrats and
their allies are doing here even if
you're losing money every month even if
you're sinking further into debt you and
your family even if you think Biden
should be in a rest home somewhere
you can't vote against him you can't
vote for change
because as their argument goes
Republicans are evil in voting against
Biden is akin to giving your thumbs up
for racism
their tactics are so transparent and
they're so cynical
but there you have it
but it doesn't have to be this way
just because Biden has given up on
America doesn't mean that we should as
well
as we go into 2024 Republicans have to
show the country and I'm talking about
the whole country not just red States
that there is a better way we can grow
this economy we can rebuild our military
we can stand up to China we can reign in
big business we know how to do it
and Republicans in state after state are
doing it
now let's take that message to New York
to Philly to Chicago yeah even San
Francisco and L.A let's save the whole
country no State and no City left behind
America has survived what almost 250
years now we certainly will not be
destroyed by Joe Biden and his cynical
handlers and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else